hi I'm Erik Bosse spider-man far from
homes indeed really knew how to keep the
fanboys chatting with bombshell after
bombshell there's about six different
rugs pulled out from underneath us
finally hardwood floor oh it's just a
rug that looks like please make that
last one it was an ugly rug but
apparently the ending that we saw in the
film was changed from an earlier version
an alternate ending in which Peter
Parker's final battle with Mysterio
a battle that the post-credits scene
suggested is far from over an alternate
ending where that battle plays out in a
completely different way essentially
more rugs I'm gonna explain what that
alternate ending was and how it could
have changed the MCU game differently
than the way far from home currently
does spoiler warning for far from home
and let's get started so in the film's
original ending spider-man confronts
Mysterio on Tower Bridge in London
finally embracing his Peter tingle
spidey sense to fight through Mysterio's
barf projected smokescreen yeah the
conflict of this movie ended up boiling
down to tingle versus barf
Peter even stopped a last-second sucker
shot from Quentin Beck and unused Edith
to destroy all the drones Peter sees
Beck died or does he believe nothing to
keep an eye on for a future episode and
then Peter takes some victory swings
with MJ back in New York but then in the
post-credits scene spider-man gets
publicly framed for all the attacks by
some fake news drummed up by Mysterio
and his team and broadcasted by Jay
jonah Jameson in a Daily Bugle dotnet
report which also publicly reveals
Peters true identity but the
screenwriters have revealed that they
considered making this identity reveal
unfold differently in an earlier version
of this story in this alternate ending
Peter would have voluntarily sacrificed
his identity out of necessity during
that final battle in London but be kind
of similar to the moment in Sam Raimi's
spider-man 2 when Peter's mask came off
when he tried to stop the train and the
survivors on that train all agreed to
keep his identity a secret as a way to
thank him for saving them but I suppose
in this far from home version Peters
appearance would be seen on a much wider
display this is a common device that
we've seen a bunch of superhero movies
like The Dark Knight in which the
villain blackmails the superhero into
revealing his true identity in order to
save some hostage or prevent further
destruction the screenwriters also wrote
versions of this alternate Indian and
witch Mysterio tricked Peter into
revealing his identity to the world and
another illusion could be kind of
similar to the moment Peter accidentally
confessed to the names of MJ Ned and
Betty has the other people who might
know about Quintin Beck's conspiracy and
then he accidentally put them all in
danger here presumably there would be
some other illusion on Tower Bridge and
then maybe Mysterio could project the
form of MJ or Ned or happy or maybe fury
again and lure Peter into eight-balls
sense of security
kind of like the ending where he tricked
him into thinking he was dead in the
ending that we saw and then right when
Peter removes his mask and maybe says
his name because he says his name
constantly another word quo the
projection fades away mysterious
actually alive and Peter is live on
camera broadcast all over the world so
why did they change this ending well the
writers said that having Peter outed
this early in the final battle would
have diminished his victory over
Mysterio they wanted to in the film with
spider-man winning for the value of
truth that Peter represents to conquer
the value of lies that Mysterio
represented if the main story of this
film doesn't end with that kind of
thematic closure you could risk robbing
the audience of the feeling of catharsis
that good movies tried to leave us with
and then after the movie as the credits
roll the post credits scenes job party
gotta open up questions again with cliff
hangers that leave us with a sense of
mystery and curiosity as we look toward
the future stories which is why they
moved peter's identity revealed to after
the credits so like after peter's
triumph in the final image the next
chapter for Peters story will be him
dealing with his greatest challenge yet
being unmasked this right of course
Peter telling nearly everyone he meets
his real name and yeah and far from home
unmasking himself upon walking into a
room filled with strangers just because
fury said it was cool yeah being framed
for terrorist attacks all over Europe
sure definitely a challenge for
spider-man in the next film but when it
comes to people knowing that he's a
dopey nerd from Queens
that is one rug pole that Tom Holland
could probably stick the landing after
which ending would you have preferred
Peter outs himself in London or the
post-credit Mysterio reveal that they
ended up going with comment down below
with your thoughts and follow me on
instagram and twitter at EI vas and
subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns and theories of everything
marvel thank you for joining me and mom
she's Devin stop stacking rugs
[Music]